bonjour jim on va parler des élections
régionales crasson va en effet un peu
parlé des élections régionales puisque
ça ça rappe ça se rapproche il se trouve
en plus qu'on recevait la semaine
dernière chantal jouanno qui est donc
candidate udi pour les régionales en île
de france
vous négociez justement en ce moment
avec lui dit pour obtenir un ralliement
de chantal jouanno à votre candidature
il ya un petit problème qui semble se
poser c'est notamment la question de la
liste sur laquelle pourraient se
retrouver chantal jouanno en cas d'union
ll nous a dit très clairement la semaine
dernière qu'elle souhaitait être
candidate dans les hauts-de-seine est ce
que c'est possible de votre côté mais
écoutez moi je vais pas parler ici est
devant vous de mes discussions avec
chantal jouanno pour la bonne et simple
raison qu avec chantal jouanno nous
parlons surtout des idées nous avons
toutes les deux le même sentiment
l'accroissement des inégalités en
ile-de-france est intolérable les
injustices sont énormes nous avons la
région la plus inégalitaire de france
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut que nous
travaillons il ya une urgence sociale et
il ya une autre urgence qui est
écologique depuis 17 ans maintenant et
c'est important depuis 17 ans ile de
france est cogérée par les différentes
parties de gauche et notamment les verts
et on n'a jamais été aussi pollué donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut changer
radicalement de politique et avec
chantal ce que nous essayons de faire
c'est d'essayer on de faire une
plateforme commune sur l'écologie avec
une éco taxe pour les poids lourds en
transit sur le social avec la création
d'un contrat d'apprentissage
régional pour l'est pour les adieux à
partir du moment où chantal jouanno pose
cette condition comme quelque chose de
sinéquanone il faut que vous répondiez à
cette condition non ça n'est pas comme
ça que les choses se peut vont se faire
nous allons trouver un terrain d'entente
vous savez dans une négociation il ya
des compromis moi ce que j'attends
surtout c'est d'avoir l'accord national
parce que tout dépend de l'accord
national nous en ile-de-france on
s'entend très bien on est tout à fait
prêts à s'unir et on trouvera les
modalités de cette union parce que les
électeurs le souhaitent et
99 maintenant j'attends l'accord
national c'est une discussion entre jean
christophe lagarde et nicolas sarkozy
est responsable
pour votre part oui mais c'est pas moi
qui ai négocié cet accord national c'est
un accord qui est politique qui inclut
beaucoup d'autres choses vous auriez
préfère le négocier justement seul avec
valérie pécresse sont les appareils de
avec chantal jouanno chantal jouanno
pardon j'ai aussi ça devrait être plus
facile
sans les partis la lourdeur de
l'appareil
c'est pas possible parce qu'en réalité
je comprends bien la position du centre
la position du centre et d'avoir une
vision globale du territoire donc je
comprends que jean christophe lagarde
soit un accord global
maintenant le sujet il est simple est-ce
que nous voulons l'alternance ou pas moi
je veut l'alternance en ile de france
vous savez que ça va être une élection
qui sera extrêmement serré vous savez
que la région est structurellement très
à gauche qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une
vraie chance de la gagner parce que je
crois que l'engagement de mes équipes et
de moi même est un engagement tellement
sincère tellement authentique et qu'on
est tellement dans les propositions et
dans les solutions que même un certain
nombre d'électeurs qui ont voté la
gauche sont prêts à lâcher la tête vous
êtes prêt à lâcher du lest peut donner
moi vous savez que je suis une femme qui
négocient j'ai négocié l'autonomie des
universités j'ai négocié la tva anti
délocalisation je suis une femme qui
sait négocier je sais écouter mes
partenaires je les respecte et je crois
qu'on pourra faire vous négociez avec le
modem c'est en bonne voie là il va y
avoir un accord qui est pas encore
définitivement entériné je les dis je
souhaite être la candidate de l'union et
l'union la plus large possible je
souhaite incarner une autre politique
nous voulons que l'île de france soit la
plus belle capitale d'europe et nous
avons tous les moyens pour y parvenir
quand on voit le chemin qui a été
parcouru par londres donc qui a 20 ans
et est vraiment une ville repoussoir
quand on voit aujourd'hui parcouru par
berlin qui était il ya vingt ans une
ville fracassé donc quand on voit le jeu
avec le modem mais en décembre je
souhaite une alliance de la droite et
des centres je les dis tous les centres
tous ceux qui veulent aujourd'hui une
alternance à françois hollande et à son
candidat c'est pas aujourd'hui qu'on
apprendra donc s'il ya eu accord
responsabilité si c'était dans ma seule
responsabilité je vous dir est beaucoup
plus alors peut-être que vous allez être
un peu plus expressif sur claude
bartolone on va parler lui maintenant il
se trouve que vous ne quittez plus d'une
semaine depuis le début de la campagne
on a comparé terre et lui peut-être que
ses méthodes mais c'est lui exactement
peut-être que ça lui on a comparé vous
agenda c'est assez frappant le 27 mai
vous êtes retrouvés côte à côte pour
l'inauguration du commissariat du raincy
le 1er juin trois jours plus tard
rebelote pour le lancement du
prolongement de la ligne 11 du métro et
le 7 juin claude bartelone fait le
marché de puteaux et vous retrouver
encore une fois à puteaux dans les
hauts-de-seine au même endroit
pourtant le l'île de france est quand
même assez grand ça
écoutez j'étais au forum emploi pour les
jeunes lycéens de villetaneuse je ne
l'est pas retrouvé j'étais à coulommiers
parler avec les agriculteurs ils n'y
étaient pas et j'étais dans un centre de
télétravail à fontainebleau n'y était
pas non plus et là à midi je vais avec
nathalie kosciusko morizet dénoncer les
hausses scandaleuse du passe navigo pour
les personnes âgées à paris je ne crois
pas que claude bartolone issoire s'il me
rejoint de temps en temps là où je suis
j'en suis très heureuse ça prouve que
bah il s'immerge quelles sont elles
aussi dans les règles tu peux
déconnecter de ces réalités francilienne
sondage ifop qui vous donnent au coude à
coude notamment 41% au deuxième tour
qu'est-ce que vous définissez comme
c'est un formidable résultat pour c'est
un formidable résultat pour moi et mes
équipes et ça montre qu'il ya une vraie
claude bartolone aussi monte dans les
sondages qu'il est à fait aux
équipements je vous rappelle que la
gauche a fait 56 % la dernière fois donc
41 vous pouvez pas dire que c'est un
triomphe pour le bloc de gauche d'être à
41 après avoir fait 56 plus chaudes et
aux sondages qui avait été réalisé sur
la candidature et côté j'imagine que si
françois hollande à ce quizz et les
militants les a empêchés de voter et
désigner leurs candidats dans une
primaire c'est bien parce qu'il pensait
que c'était un meilleur candidat moi je
vais vous dire ce que je pense c'est que
les franciliens ce qu'ils veulent c'est
des compositions ils veulent des
solutions et ils veulent une région qui
soit une région qui n'exclut personne
c'est pour ça que j'ai proposé un pacte
régional pour les territoires ruraux
pour que ces territoires se sentent
inclus pour qu'il n'ait pas l'impression
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui des candidats qui
ne leur parle avec ne s'intéresse pas à
eux merci jim joyce et fondre cet
éclairage